Es ist der Tummelplatz
der Reichen und Schönen:
der Schweizer Ort St. Moritz
im Herzen der Alpen.
Hier trifft Luxus auf
internationalen Jetset.
Doch auch Ursprüngliches gibt es zu sehen –
wie den sogenannten „schiefen Turm“
der St.-Mauritius-Kirche aus dem
12. Jahrhundert –
und moderne Akzente wie
dieses Apartmenthaus,
entworfen vom britischen
Stararchitekten Norman Foster.
St. Moritz ist vor allem als Wintersportort
bekannt. Aber Urlauber kommen auch im
Sommer auf ihre Kosten. Vor allem jene,
die eine sportliche Herausforderung suchen.
Denn in den warmen Monaten werden
sonst schneebedeckte Pisten
zu Wanderwegen und
Mountainbike-Trails.
Dave Spielmann war früher Schweizer
Banker und hat dann umgesattelt.
Heute führt er Mountainbike-Touren.
In seinen Gruppen fahren Menschen
fast jeden Alters mit. Es braucht allerdings
schon ein bisschen Mut.
Es gibt ganz unterschiedliche Trails hier,
von steinig, verblockt, schwierig
bis zu den gebauten Flowtrails, und die
sind eigentlich für jedermann machbar.
Aber man muss Mountainbiken
können. Es reicht nicht,
wenn man nur in
der Stadt Fahrrad gefahren ist.
Also, hier im Engadin ist natürlich
der Wintersport immer noch King,
und im Sommer wird Mountainbiken
immer mehr zur Queen.
Beliebt sind im Sommer auch Kite-
und Windsurfen.
Hier auf dem Silvaplanersee, nur sieben
Kilometer von St. Moritz entfernt,
können die Surfer ihre
Fähigkeiten testen.
Alex Panier hat seine französische Heimat
vor elf Jahren verlassen,
um hier als Windsurf-Lehrer zu arbeiten.
Nach seiner Meinung sind die Bedingungen
besser als irgendwo sonst, obwohl der
Wind heute mal nicht ganz so stark bläst.
Wir sind nicht so weit vom Strand.
Es gibt keine großen Wellen.
Der Wind ist immer da.
Wir haben verschiedene Ecken,
wo der Wind stärker und
weniger stark [ist], so vom Anfänger
[bis] zum Professionellen haben wir
die besten Verhältnisse.
Eine typische Schweizer Spezialität
ist Schokolade –
so wie hier in der Confiserie Hanselmann
mitten in der Altstadt,
eines der ältesten Cafés in St. Moritz.
Schon seit 1894 gehen hier
Einheimische und Touristen
ein und aus.
Also, bei uns ist der Renner die Nusstorte,
weil die ganz berühmt ist.
Und viele Gäste – auch aus dem Ausland –
kaufen das,
weil das ist die Spezialität
von der ganzen Region Engadin.
Und mit Schokolade ... Wir haben
die speziellen Pralinen.
Das sehen Sie hier alles.
Und wir haben verschiedene Sorten,
Trüffel. Die haben Sie ohne Alkohol  –
die da – oder haben Sie mit Alkohol und
dann verschiedene andere Sorten.
Das ist vom Geschmack her
vom Kunden [abhängig].
Wer den Tag ganz entspannt ausklingen
lassen möchte, kann sich ein bisschen
Wellness in einem der Luxushotels
von St. Moritz gönnen.
Gleich fünf davon gibt es im Umkreis
von nur vier Kilometern.
Im Badrutt's Palace Hotel arbeitet Marinella
Negri seit fünf Jahren im Spa-Bereich.
Sie ist Spezialistin für
ayurvedische Massagen.
Wir bieten verschiedene Behandlungen,
aber ich wende vor allem Ayurveda an.
Das ist besonders gut, um den Körper
zu reinigen und zu entgiften.
Eine Erfrischung für Körper und Geist sind
das klare Wasser von St. Moritz
und die frische Bergluft allemal.
Und anders als die meisten Dinge hier
gibt es diese Aussicht sogar umsonst!